so
you can go well you're on this side or
you're on that side it's like no i'm
going to do a piecemeal
i'm just going to pick and choose the
stuff i think is right and and sometimes
it'll be on this side and sometimes
it'll be on that side but at least
you'll know
well that's the way it's supposed to be
that's the way that that's what's going
on you just get ridiculed from both
sides because you're piecemealing he
doesn't give a [ __ ] you don't care
look i i've i've i've sat it at tables
at brunch in it with with
i'll give you an example i'll give you a
perfect example the fact that it's
brunch we know what side it is well we
went to maui yes we did we're rallying
you graciously invited us on your rented
catamaran which is lovely and very
gracious and and we were i was sitting
at a table
and i'm sitting with all my progressive
friends and we're all going out to maui
and having a good time
and for some reason the subject of leaf
blowers came up and and oh they're so
loud and it's makes a mess i hate
breathing it in or whatever and i said
yeah everyone hated it they were walking
their dog and the guy's blowing the leaf
blower around the street and everything
and i said you know it's they've had an
ordinance against it in la for since
like 1996. it's it's illegal essentially
and they go how come it's not in force
these guys are blowing it wakes me up in
the morning blah blah blah and i said
well the majority of the people with
leaf blowers are poor mexicans
essentially those are the gardeners and
it's kind of a bad
look bad optics to take these poor
people and arrest them or give them
summonses or whatever we have a
progressive government here and they're
just not going to enforce this thing but
it's it's on the books and everyone got
angry at me they were like that's racist
and come on and that's not what's going
on and i said
it is what's going on i've read articles
on it i understand it and i had about 11
people at the table all turn against me
and these are these are wives and
friends and children i know they are
they're all of them right and they're
all looking at me going what kind of
racist [ __ ] is this and i go
[ __ ] you i i'm just telling you what it
is and i ruined the brunch and i turned
everyone against me but my feeling was
like
i happen to know what's going on
you don't right i know it's 11 against
one
but i'm not going to join your side that
doesn't know what's going on just
because i'm outnumbered what did your
wife say to you after the brunch it's
well everyone knows
who i am so they then i get written off
it's like okay he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about and i'm always
like just go look it up there's a big la
times article i read from 1999 it's on
it's on the internet
it is
well the la times article is on the
internet you can go look it up i mean
that's what's going on
okay you don't like the way that sounds
that's your problem i'm just
i'm just a convey i'm just a conduit for
what is is happening or give me another
opinion that would explain this thing
being illegal but folks with the leaf
blowers being ubiquitous on any any
given weekday in suburbia here and no
one could offer anything so i'm
perfectly fine with you not being
popular you know you don't win
later on i explained why i hated the
beastie boys and then turned the table
against me even even to a sharper decree
but i'm i'm fine
it's it's it's not a popularity contest
it's what is it because they're jews
the table no beastie boys oh the beast
that's right and you know how many
beastie boys were in those towers on 9
11 none none
wow
that's the circle of life
[Music]